gabriel j'ai un problème je ne peux pas
résister une femme c'est plus fort que
moi il se passe un phénomène physique je
suis une espèce d'amoureux permanent non
je me fasse un qu'il en arrive à être
une addiction
roulades si vous pouvez pas résister aux
femmes comment comptez vous gérer votre
relation avec moi je vais pas vous le
cacher les jolie brune au regard
pétillant et goscinny enchaîné mais
aussi pourquoi pas signer poursuivre et
toi vous observez 24 heures sur 24
non mais c'est pas possible je vis avec
mon tonton jaws sa femme l'a quitté il
ya deux ans et demi c'est pas négociable
tant de questions aériennes aucune femme
ne rentre ici pas dans le temple balesi
retrait je vous montrez votre chambre
enfin machin et vous bah je me disais
comme le litre est grand on va pas se
gêner
ok on va complètement gêné je vais
dormir sur le canapé on passerait à des
jauges un sourire ou les soirs lui
parlerai jamais allé elle m'a giflé avec
ses nichons tu appelles ça comment toi
et giffa des gifles au plafond
j'ai tout essayé je sais plus quoi faire
on a rencontré ton assistante elle a
l'air bonne compétente peut fêter la cat
là bas
je laime ça va pas gd sur six
ok c'est quoi ça à chaque fois que vous
aurez l'impulsion de séduire une femme
que du professionnel plus pour être sûr
vous allez pas enlever petit chat
c'est vrai je connais pas un peu plus de
temps je sais pas si vous avez quelque
chose de prévu
que me
[Applaudissements]
stark
tu te rends compte que depuis qu'il
s'occupe de moi j'ai pas séduit une
seule fille
j'ai un très bon test je ne serai pas me
contrôler je peux le contrôler